it's the confirmation that this
temporary change which will apply in
england from the 11th of january and
actually has happened before it happened
last year was in place from january to
march means that if you are
experiencing symptoms if you like the
traditional symptoms of covid19 now
those would be a cough loss of taste or
smell or a temperature then you will
need to isolate and you will still need
to get a pcr test but if you're taking a
lateral flow test just in the normal
course of your daily life and you happen
to get a positive result then you won't
need to confirm that with a pcr anymore
that's the significant change you will
still need to isolate that isolation
period remains at seven days with those
tests on day six and seven in order to
ensure that you can leave isolation at
that point as long as you are negative
but these changes as you heard from
jillian keegan there come into place
because the prevalence of covid19 at the
moment across the country is so high
that the chances of getting a false
positive on a lateral flow test have
reduced significantly so the scientists
and experts agree that at this point in
time it makes more sense to free up the
capacity in the testing system the pcr
testing system for those who have those
significant symptoms and for everyone
else with a lateral flow test just to
isolate now the really key point here is
that people are still being asked to
report those positive pc at those
positive lateral flow tests to the
government now that matters because the
government needs to know how many people
are testing positive it also matters
because they might want to sequence any
any changes any different variants and
they also need people to still go
through the track and trace process so
it doesn't mean that you can't register
your result you will still need to do
that using that qr code on the top of
the test but it does mean that you don't
need to send off for a pcr test anymore
making the system slightly less
overburdened because we know that there
are many many people
trying to get those confirmatory pcr
tests going back to work trying to
confirm with employers that they will
need to do so so the system has become
overstretched it's been very difficult
it's also incredibly expensive now there
will be some exceptions to these changes
for people for example if you're getting
the 500 pound test and trace support
payment you will still need to do a pcr
test to confirm that you can get that to
be part of a surveillance program you
may still be asked to get a pcr test
regardless and for around a million
people in england who are at extra risk
they will be sent pcr test kits there'll
be no change there because they are in a
different category they may well have
more risk from this disease than other
people but i think this change signifies
the fact that boris johnson who remember
is going to give a statement to
parliament later on this afternoon is
trying to move the country to a position
where we live with covert 19 and where
we try and free up some of that capacity
perhaps try and reduce some of the
amount of money that's being spent on
the testing system remember though this
is only temporary and we all know with
covert 19 things can change quite
quickly if there were any potential
changes they could reintroduce this need
to get a pcr test but for the moment we
don't know when it will end being
introduced from the 11th of january in
england you won't need a confirmative
pcr if you test positive on a lateral
flow